Great. Well, amazing to be here, Gaddy
team, the whole team. I mean, it's such
an incredible community. Um, I'm
Heather. Uh, I work at Google and I do
cyber cyber cyber stuff. I'm joined by u
my amazing colleague for uh who leads
security and privacy for Deep Mind.
Please send him all the prompt injection
bugs. Uh, not me. Um, I want to maybe
start just by setting the scene a little
bit. I think it's an understatement for
all of you to say that this is an
unprecedented time. We will all look
back on the I think the year 2026
as the year everything pivoted. Um, and
we will also think of 2026
as a simpler time. I think it's going to
get a little bit harder and a little bit
more complex. Um,
we are not far off from a world where
there will be an open- source full
hacking tool where you can type in go
hack Google and a week later it'll come
back with a root prompt. Uh, we're not
far off. Um, and we know this for a few
reasons. Number one, there are now open-
source frameworks for doing pentesting,
finding, you know, simple
vulnerabilities in web apps, etc. I did
a little back of the ma uh back of the
napkin math as well. There's about a
billion dollars of VC money going into
startups for vulnerability discovery,
pen testing, red team simulation. So
between all the good guys and all the
bad guys, I think it's fair to say we
are at a point where we'll be able to
find every vulnerability in every system
with Agentic frameworks and that's going
to be a completely different world. Um
it's going to change the way we think
about vulnerabilities, the way we rank
them, prioritize them. We'll have to
change the CVSS scoring system because
it won't be meaningful anymore.
Um there will be a world where we just
have too many vulnerabilities. And to
give you some sense, we are already
seeing it. Um, I checked this morning
and the, uh, vulnerability database, the
NVD has a 30,000 backlog unanalyzed
vulnerability queue. But even given
that, between 24 and 25, there was a 35%
increase in logged uh, vulnerabilities
that got a CVE. And not every bug that
gets um, discovered gets a CVE. So we're
already seeing kind of a a cataclysmic
increase fairly significantly. And that
brings us to the impetus for the project
we're going to talk about today. Um big
sleep and code mender. These are two
projects uh research projects out of uh
Google and Google deep mind with one
goal and one real deep meaning that I
want to leave with uh all of you today.
Next slide is that we simply must
eliminate every software vulnerability
on Earth.
And that is the legacy that people in
this room need to leave behind to the
next generation of technologists.
And it is not a simple problem. It is
not an easy one, but it is the one that
we have to solve because as humanity
goes beyond Earth, we just simply need
to not be dealing with cross-sight
scripting bugs.
And um we have a little ambition at
Google to get rid of memory safety bugs
as well. And that is what we're going to
talk a little bit about today. Um on top
of finding every bug, we have to be able
to give developers the tools to not make
them anymore.
And uh the technology we're going to
talk about here today um also lends
itself to that. Uh next slide.
So, I'm pretty sure everybody who's
played with an LLM has pointed it at
some code and said, "Please find me a
bug." And it's actually pretty good. Um,
even the older models are pretty good.
And as we have the new generations
coming out successfully,
um, kind of every kind of 3 to four
months, we're seeing a massive
improvement in what the large language
models can do about reasoning about
code.
Um, we wanted to go one step further and
not just look at the shallow bugs that
are easy to find.
but to really look at the kinds of bugs
that top elite researchers uh can find.
There was a 2017 study, a RAND study
that showed um just how long an expert
vulnerability
researcher takes to find kind of a
deeply embedded bug. I think it's
somewhere on the order of a month for
finding the bug and about 22 days um for
exploitation successfully.
But what if you could build an agentic
reasoning system that could do that in a
matter of hours or minutes and you could
find the deep bugs much faster, more
reliably, and potentially early in the
software development life cycle. So the
approach that the big sleep team has
taken to finding bugs is not just to use
the LLM for the basic things you can
prompt it to do, but actually to
recreate the human expertise of our
project zero team. Project Zero is a
team that's been around for over a
decade. Their goal is to get rid of zero
days. They haven't been successful yet,
but they think they're going to get
there with this technology. So, they
want to recreate that uh kind of deep
researcher experience with three things
also in mind. Number one, we want
uncompromising quality. We do not want
to produce AI slop with the bugs we
find. We want everything that lands in a
developer's hands, especially an
inexperienced developer, to just work
out of the box. Number two, we need this
to be cost effective and efficient at
scale. We have trillions of lines of
code on the planet, billions of lines of
code at Google. Um, and we want to run
this all the time. So, it's got to be
fast and efficient. And third, as real
time as possible. Right? Right now,
we're all looking at brownfield code. So
stuff that's already launched in
production, open source code, stuff
that's already out there, we want to be
able to put it in the developers user
journey so that they're not launching
new bugs in the future as well. And we
think if we do this, if we get it right,
um, we can probably be creating and
maintaining code that's relatively
bug-free in the next couple of years,
right? This is kind of within not only
our ambition, but our capabilities with
the tech. Uh, next slide. So let's talk
um about big sleep. And I'm not going to
do like you know code reading here or
anything. We're going to talk
architecture a little bit. Um one of the
first things we realized as we studied
how the researchers work is that they
become deeply expert in the codebase
they're working in. And if you've ever
met a really good bone researcher they
kind of tend to get you know deep and
niche in one area or two areas. And the
way they do this is they understand the
code. um they look at the kinds of bugs
that they've had in the code before,
past vulnerabilities, they do variant
analysis
um and they have a really good
understanding of the code architecture.
Okay, so we have to give that to this
agentic reasoning system as well. So we
harness that and that's phase one.
We then enter into uh phase two which is
this agentic framework that's working
constantly in a loop feeding back to
itself. It's building hypotheses perhaps
based on past bugs. For example, here's
a part of the code that I think might be
vulnerable. Let me test that hypothesis.
To do that, it needs tools. Okay, it
needs a debugger. It needs the code
browser and it needs a Python
interpreter so that it can write scripts
for itself. So what it's doing is that
it's not just prompting itself. It's
building code. It's building test cases
and it's able to test its own hypothesis
and see if there's success and failure.
And it's doing that constantly in a
loop. Right? This is far beyond just
prompting, you know, find the cross-
sight scripting bug in this code. Okay.
Um, and it's this hypothesis and uh
revision that really gives the system
that feel of like an expert researcher,
right? And if you've if you've ever met
them, they sometimes are just standing
in the corner staring with their coffee
going, you know, I can't get that bug. I
can't get that bug. This is what the LLM
um reasoning loop is doing. Once it has
a successful crash that it thinks uh
might be a valid vulnerability, we then
move into the verification phase. Um and
it's looking at feedback data that's
coming out of the debugger. Um and it is
actually then building an exploit.
Okay. And this proof of vulnerability is
so key to getting the false positive
rate to zero. And we've managed to do
that. So every bug that comes out of
there is not only a candidate for an
exploit um for vulnerability, but it's
actually provably a vulnerability. We
then write a report and again it's the
it's Gemini writing the report. It's not
a human. Um it's got the proof of
vulnerability code so the developer can
test it. It has a high quality report
that does a step by step through every
function, every part of the bug. It
explains the bug in detail so that if
you have a non-expert developer, they're
going to understand what's going on. And
we've managed to do this to the extent
where endto-end fully automated without
a human involvement, we're getting zero
false positives. And these are deep
memory safety bugs, right? These are not
cross-sight scripting bugs. These are
not uh kind of shallow integer
overflows. They're kind of deep uh in
the codebase. Um and we've put them all
online. That's the URL down there. Um
our issue tracker. So you can go in and
see them um and see the quality of the
report and um kind of I think all but
five are fixed at this point. So as I
checked this morning so that's big
sleep. This is just the vulnerability
discovery. We've done one half of the
job for the developer. Now we've got to
do the part that really sucks as a
developer which is fixing the code. And
for that I'm going to pass it to four.
>> All right. Great. Thanks Heather. All
right. So let's zoom out for a minute. I
want to speed up a little because I want
to make sure that we have time for
questions, but I have a lot to cover.
So, we said we're going to try to fix
every security vulnerability on Earth,
and we're not kidding. So, what does
that mean? There's a whole bunch of
other pieces besides the big sleeve
component, right? So, finding
vulnerabilities is one part, but also we
have to help the developers patch those
vulnerabilities. I'll talk more about
that in just a second. Uh, but one other
thing that I want to make sure we at
least touch on, we're not going to talk
about it in detail today, is that also
brand new green field code that's being
generated through Vibe coding frameworks
actually needs to be secure out of the
box as well. And so that's something
else we're working on. We don't have
time to talk about that today, but we
think it's a completed thought, right?
Where if you have legacy code that we
can find vulnerabilities in it and we
can get those automatically patched.
That's the middle to the top arrow. If
we have legacy code, we can actually
proactively harden that code. I'll talk
about that in a minute. And then
finally, brand new code should be secure
as much as possible out of the box. Not
just free of vulnerabilities, but
actually using secure frameworks so
those vulnerabilities aren't possible in
the first place. So we're working on all
of this. Uh but let me dive in a little
bit more into the the code mener
component specifically. Right. So this
is basically how codemen works. is a
project we started last year in
recognition that this AI von apocalypse
which by the way is a word that you
should take away from this conference
the vone apocalypse is coming and so we
think we should actually help arm the
community with tools to solve this
problem so it's not enough to find
vulnerabilities we should also help the
the the developers patch code now what
are the three components of patching
code you want to make sure one that the
patch fixes the security vulnerability
right two that it doesn't break the code
in some way that changes the
functionality, right? And then three, as
much as possible, you actually want to
honor the idioms of the developer that
had built that code previously, so that
it's not just a patch for the
vulnerability, but it's done in the way
that the developer finds easy to digest
and understand. So all three of those
things is what codemen is built to
solve. So how does it work? Well, it
takes in either a a verified
vulnerability from big sleep and the
idea is to make this a full endto-end
discovery and fixing engine, right? What
that runs completely without human
intervention. Um, the other piece that
I'm not sure we have time to talk about
today is hardening. Basically, in a
nutshell, what this is is basically
proactively looking at a codebase for
things like pointer exceptions and
modifying the code through a a larger
patch to make sure that all of those
buffers are protected before the
vulnerability can actually occur in the
first place. So, you can imagine a
similar process to patching actually
being used to harden code and protect
pointers as well, but I won't go into
that in detail. So, the LLM agent
actually has very similar access to
tools and environment like Heather just
discussed, right? It can do things like
debugging. It can test hypothesis. What
that does is it creates a number of
patch candidates, right? That are
potential fixes, but that's not good
enough, right? We need to verify that
those patches. And so some of the secret
sauce of what we've been building is
actually in these verification stages.
And we've done a huge amount of work
here. So we have verifiers of all kinds.
And it's actually a pluggable system. So
we actually fuzz the variables before
and after the patch to validate that the
functionality hasn't been destroyed by
the patch. We actually do formal
verification of that section of the
codebase to try to prove that that code
still is functionally equivalent. We
actually also look for differential
testing. We actually do a round of
fuzzing of the code with a potential
candidate patch to make sure that the
vulnerability is still not present by
injecting the the the the malicious
inputs into that section of the
codebase. Um and finally, we use of
course uh maybe the most obvious of all
options. we use the LL an LLM itself to
view the patch uh with a very carefully
crafted um pre-prompt to try to
determine if that patch is also accurate
as well. So that's not all that we do,
but it's a good sense of the types of
things that we do. And it's only once
the patches all pass the verifier um
that we would actually consider that
something that's a candidate to send to
the community. In some cases, none of
the patches actually pass validation and
the learnings from the validation
failures are actually fed back into the
context window for the LLM to to learn
from the mistake and try to improve to a
new set of candidate patches that are
then in turn validated and ranked for
submission. Um, so that's essentially
how codemen works. Um, just a couple
notes here. We've got 178 fixes now in
open source that have been autonomously
generated through code mender. Um, we
have uh a pass through a couple of
different libraries, open source
libraries. Lib WP is one example. We've
done a bunch of work in Chrome as well
to actually harden pointers in the
codebase through automatically generated
patches to to to harden those pointers.
Um, and um, of course, we're working on
on doing this for internal Google
systems. I think probably one criticism
of of of our approach here that I I
think you could levy is that we are
maybe being too cautious in making sure
that we have highly verified outputs for
the community before we send something
out. Um, we've taken a position that we
really firmly believe in quality and
that people trusting the system is
what's going to lead us to be able to
accelerate the community's adoption of
this technology. Um, I guess we'll see
how it plays out. I think other folks
have a different trade-off on the dial
of sort of quicker to market. um but
maybe tolerating, you know, more
developer toil. Um you know, I think
we're we're we're we're trying to figure
out where the right line is there. Um I
won't go into all the details here on
the bottom except to recognize the fact
that all of this is well and good, but
those of us in the hallway here in the
in the room all know that one of the
hardest problems with patching is
actually places in the in the world that
struggle to actually apply patches in a
timely manner. And so that's another
problem. I don't know how to solve that
with AI. if you do come find me and I I
will be very excited to talk to you. Um
but I think this is an important part of
the puzzle is uh being able to get the
community and the world to patch our
code bases at the speed of AI. Um okay
and with that um I guess we'll take
questions um with a few minutes left. So
I don't know how questions work by the
way. So okay there's mics um around. So
if you have a question raise your hand
and I guess somehow a mic will show up.
Yeah, there's a gentleman here in the
front and Heather's gonna answer all the
questions [laughter]
>> because you don't know how they work.
Okay,
>> I can't hear you.
>> Yeah, to turn it on. Just flip it.
>> Just flip the switch up.
>> I can just
>> If you shout, I'll repeat.
>> Okay. Oh, yeah. So I'm just wondering uh
how similar or different this is from
OpenAI's adwork that was recently
released because I was uh reading about
it. It does something similar but so
would be interesting to know like and I
don't know if you have done any sort of
like comparison as to how yours is.
Yeah. So that's
>> I don't know are the OpenAI guys here?
Do they want to say
>> where you at?
>> Where are you at?
>> And uh just to add sorry just to add I
think uh
Um to to seriously answer your question,
um we've not done a side-by-side
comparison because neither team has
published full details. Um but I I think
it's fair to say we're both using um
kind of, you know, agentic reasoning u
behind them, but we'll see as the
>> things develop as as they come out.
>> Y question
>> with the
>> there's one here and then there. Yeah.
with the techniques you've used in Big
Sleep, they seem very focused on memory
safety vulnerabilities, which are a huge
problem. Uh I'm curious how much of
these tech how many of these techniques
do you think would be applicable to
things with a less clear signal than
just a SEG fault or some of these uh
more difficult to find things than
memory vulnerabilities?
>> Yeah, I I'm just say quickly it does
definitely apply. I mean, the team's
finding shallow bugs as well. um what
we're targeting with the research is the
deep stuff because it's harder and a
little more esoteric. But
>> yeah. Yeah. I mean I don't really have a
lot to add. I I think a lot of the
techniques actually carry over to web
vulnerabilities and shallow
vulnerabilities quite well. I think the
verification techniques um of the
vulnerability are different to your
point. Um but you know injected faults
whether it's input validation you know
things like that I think all of it will
work and we're we're building all of
that stuff as well um to make sure that
we work for web vulnerabilities both
finding and fixing. So yeah, that's a
good question.
>> I guess I will say um I mean we're still
doing a lot of fuzzing. We develop OSS
fuzz at Google. Um doing tons of
fuzzing, but big sleep is finding things
the fuzzers are missing. Uh so that
tells us that we're we're targeting at
the right depths probably in the code.
>> Yeah, my my question is related to
business logic vulnerabilities that
don't have necessarily a signature but
are in the context of how the
application's used. How are you all
thinking about those types of
vulnerability classes in your approach?
And do you think this methodology would
apply to that specific class of
vulnerabilities?
>> I think right now most of our research
is not on business applications. It's on
kind of infrastructure components like
um
>> you know the the V8
>> um uh part of Chrome which we sandbox
and you know we wish it was better. So
um those components or something like
the um uh ffmpeg is another one that
we've looked at quite a bit because it's
job is to handle untrusted input
>> right
>> um how it translates to business
applications we're not sure yet. So
>> thank you
>> folks I'm going to cut down the Q&A but
please remember you can always find the
speakers on Slack as well as talk to
them later when they're here. Thank you
so much for and I'll have you know by
the way
they're
That's a lot of appreciation right there
that their titles don't say this, but
four is the CISO++ of DeepMind, right?
And Heather is the sister of Google.
They just don't say that. They're not
allowed to say these things, so I'll
embarrass them here and say it. So,
thank you so much for coming and
speaking with us.